It's undeniable that the cloud has
changed how organizations interact with
information in their data center. And
it's certainly true that many
organizations no longer even have an on
premises data center. That's because we
can run practically any technology in
the cloud. All we need is enough
bandwidth and we're able to move that
technology to any place we'd like in the
world. This allows organizations to put
all of their data in the cloud and then
be able to access that data from
anywhere they happen to be. And of
course, if you need additional storage
space, additional CPU processing, or
more network access, you can simply add
that to your existing cloud
infrastructure. A good example of a
service that we moved very quickly to
the cloud was our email infrastructure.
Now, many organizations have taken an
email server that used to be at their
local facility and they're now running
that email server in the cloud. In the
cloud, we commonly have redundant
connectivity to all of these cloud-based
services and usually it's over a very
high-speed network connection. These
cloud services also commonly have
integrated redundancy and backup options
so that your data is always available
and if you do need to restore
information, there is always a recent
backup available. And not only do these
cloud-based data centers have very
strong physical security, they have a
well integrated security for all of the
apps and services that are running on
their cloud infrastructure. And you may
be using a cloud-based email service
already. Your organization may be using
Outlook in the Microsoft cloud or you
may be using Google Workspace email or
other types of cloud-based email
services.
Another useful advantage of cloud-based
services is that there is an almost
unlimited amount of storage space
available on these cloud
infrastructures. If you need more
storage space, you only need to purchase
more storage space for your system. We
can also integrate this cloud-based
storage with clients that were running
on our desktop systems. So, we can store
a file locally on our local storage
drive. that file is automatically
uploaded to the cloud and synchronized
across all of our other systems that
have that same client running. This
allows us to store information in one
place and have that single file
replicated to all of our important
devices. For example, if you're using
something like Google Drive, you can
choose which files and which folders you
would like to synchronize into the
cloud. This allows you to mirror those
files so that all of the files on your
system are also mirrored to all of your
other systems. or you can choose to
simply store everything in the cloud and
you can retrieve that from the cloud
when you want to use
it. We become very accustomed to
collaborating with others using
cloud-based systems. For example, it's
very common now to turn on your camera
and be part of a group that's having a
meeting. This is something that allows
you to share spreadsheet information and
financial data. You might want to do
video conferencing or do presentations
over this collaboration tool. or you may
be all editing the same word processing
document and everybody can see those
changes as they're being made in real
time. And of course, if you're in a
large organization, you're probably
using instant messaging and that instant
messaging is synchronized using
cloud-based services. This means that
you don't have to be an employee in a
particular building on a particular
floor. You can have a laptop and
effectively work from anywhere in the
world. Having different people access
different cloud services from different
locations brings a bit of complexity
when it comes to identifying who that
user is and if they have access to those
resources. Fortunately, there are
services in the cloud that provide
identity synchronization. So instead of
having a single directory that is stored
in your corporate data center, you can
instead have multiple directories stored
in many places around the world in
different cloud environments. For
example, you might be using Microsoft
Intra ID, Octa, or Google Identity. This
also synchronizes any changes across all
of those different repositories. So when
you make one change to a user's profile,
those changes are pushed out to all of
those different identity providers. This
also means that we don't have to go from
identity provider to identity provider
just to make sure that we've added a new
user or removed somebody from the
directory. We can simply add the user in
one place and those changes are pushed
out to all of those different identity
providers. These resources in the cloud
have also changed the way that we
license the applications. That's because
the applications were using may be
anywhere on the internet at a cloud
provider instead of being installed onto
a storage drive on our local laptop.
This is why many people have moved this
licensing process to the cloud. You
don't have to have separate paper
licenses or separate physical licensing
keys. You can instead centralize the
management of all of those license keys
on one single management front end. This
could also save you money because you
can see every license that you own. And
if you have certain users that are not
currently using that application, you
can move those licenses over to a
different user instead of purchasing
more licenses for the organization.
Here's the front end of a cloud-based
licensing manager. You can see a number
of keys have been created for an
application and we can use those license
keys and push them out to a specific
user who will now be able to have access
to that application. If we need to
change that assignment, we simply go
back to this management front end and
make those changes from this cloud-based
infrastructure.